un barbecue sur des airs de tournée
politique pour le rassemblement national
après le changement de nos missions
remobilisation des militants et cadres
locaux alors que se profilent les
élections européennes mais surtout
municipal en 2020 le parti de marine le
pen espère nouer des alliances avec les
différents partis de droite
le département des yvelines pourrait
être une terre idéale pour ses ambitions
aujourd'hui nous nous sommes dans cette
démarche d'ouverture de rassemblement
nous voulons parler avec tous ceux qui
partagent notre vision c'est à dire que
la nation est le meilleur cadre pour
l'expression démocratique du peuple est
le meilleur cadre protecteur de notre
identité de notre prospérité économique
de nos solidarités et c'est je crois un
trait que nous avons en commun avec un
certain nombre de personnalités
politiques y compris dans ce département
il y a quatre ans l'ex front national
avait conquis à mantes-la-ville sa seule
mairie francilienne pour amplifier le
mouvement en 2020 le parti discute déjà
avec les représentants locaux de debout
la france et du parti chrétien démocrate
c'est dans les yvelines aussi que se
trouve la terre d'élection de jean
frédéric poisson très pragmatiquement
certaines personnes nous appellent en
disant voilà vous représentez tant de
points face à nourrir les personnes qui
ont vraiment salit la politique locale
donc il fallait agir et donc ça c'est
des choses qu'on arrive tout à fait
entendre
donc voilà c'est un mois de réflexion
c'est comment après ans à ménages comme
on travaille tous ensemble malgré nos
petites divergences mais malgré aussi
notre entente sur l'essentiel
pour espérer conquérir plusieurs mairies
et asseoir son ancrage local le
rassemblement national devra largement
amélioré ses résultats électoraux dans
le département lors du premier tour de
la présidentielle le fn était arrivé et
seulement en quatrième position derrière
notamment la france insoumise
[Applaudissements]